I think it'd be fun they prepare for
something like
organic farming yeah I grow a lot of my
own food yeah recipes so here's the
thing all right I I don't do recipes I
it's like I create you know what I mean
I don't measure anything i just know
together it's like oh that's good
this is what I got you know this was
plentiful right now this is in season I
just throw it together and most of the
time it's not really good not all the
time but but most of the time it's like
yeah and I can never make the same thing
twice it's just laughs I function you
know i'm just like this free-flowing
artist it's just like throwing all
over and I like to make salsa especially
if I have fresh stuff and then i have
this I have this mulberry tree that
gives us amazing berries so I make a lot
of stuff with that I make teas I make
all these kind of fruit fruit teas and
stuff I have all kinds of herbs and mint
and stuff like that and I I make really
good drinks and then
no I'm not knock on it was just like tea
and stuff you know and i'll mix fruit in
it what else I make a lot of stuff with
eggs because I you know I have a crow
eggs so I mean and I think the best
things or stuff that come right off your
farm if you can just grow something and
beat it right then it's really it's
different its most people have no clue
what that's like to grab something
that's growing and eat it right then
it's different it's better it's
different and it's better and most
people don't know it you know they're
missing seventy percent of what there's
there because it's it's such a different
experience to eat something that's alive
Wow sorry you missing out if you get a
farm like me we were going to get you a
slushie over there not into that what
does it a recipe that you probably
you see I mean I make a lot of songs so
you know I'll just get the tomatoes from
my yard and I have all these herbs and
I'll just make that stuff and it's like
whatevers whatever's coming you know
I'll just turn it into salsa just eat it
with with chips or tortilla chips or
something like that yeah I mean
so but I just really bad it like
following directions written directions
and measuring stuff i don't i don't do
that i'll just go in yeah and then I'll
taste it I thought all that taste good
or I can tell audience a little bit of
this
I think different sure right there yeah
you